ladies and gentlemen it is a wild week
the Republican party in Colorado says
that if they remove Trump from the
ballot as it appears they have they will
not even have a primary they're
threatening to withdraw from the primary
system and convert to a caucus system
and they're telling VI ramaswami you you
need not pull out because we're going to
convert to a caucus so this would
basically nullify what this ruling says
but that's not completely true the
ruling would also bar Trump from the
general election as well so if they
convert from a primary to a caucus sure
Trump can still win the caucus system
and then maybe become the nominee but
doesn't mean he can be in the general
election in Colorado which means I
believe about 1.5 to 1.8 million
Republican votes removed from the
popular vote count we have a lot to
discuss as it pertains to this now of
course VI ramaswami said he would drop
out he called on Ron Christie Nikki
Haley do the same Ronda santz has come
out boldly saying no way he will not
drop out because he doesn't think it's
legitimate anyway he thinks the ruling
will be overturned